okay let's talk about that middle-class
famous tour baby those sweet sweet live
shows
about to be kicking into high gear it's
a stand-up comedy show with a little ayg
that we play with the crowd great way to
introduce new people to the show so grab
the squad grab the homies grab the bozos
grab your best girl grab your best guy
and come out and see us yeah guys uh
first date is gonna be red bank new
jersey that it will sell out get those
tickets and we're in seattle portland
kansas city springfield st louis
nashville come on and up there to indy
get your tickets like big man said it's
a great time these live shows are
bonkers you've seen the clips link in
the description do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage oh yeah little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they go to be classy or
if they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host age foley coming at you on
a beautiful day we're down here at
antoni's basement she had said that she
had got fireworks for the fourth okay i
go upstairs there's a crate of
flashbangs up there
[Laughter]
she's shacking up with some guy on the
swat team i told her i still got all
that scuba gear in the garage from the
search and rescue guy
my co-host is coming at you
you had me on flashbang big ah nothing
like getting greedy you know what i'm
saying gang the american way
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he's the ceo of ru garbage he
is an international businessman and he
is not to be trifled with in the board
room or the bedroom give it up for kj
kevin james ryan hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes please
full video available on youtube as you
know those numbers are
and then obviously um
oh what is it is it
google.com ashjeeves.com
can [ __ ] suck it i'm a [ __ ]
samyang man it's called patreon.com are
you cool
that's a real good time get a bunch of
bonus content get episodes ayg uh
episodes of hard feelings which is a
completely different podcast we do all
together you get those weekly get uh
live streams a whole nine yards check it
though look out yes sir please do and
come see us on the road gang we're all
over today
just added new cities too and how about
a nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good he crosses the t's and he
dots the eyes give it up for the good
one toby mcmullen hey what's up dudes
oh man it's gonna be a sick one we got a
guy who knows how to [ __ ] live in
here he does he really does real fun
dudes life champion and all time parties
he's got a bottle of [ __ ] pinot gris
behind it
and it looks cold
which i assume you're going to some park
to watch somebody
play the cello or something and sip on
that no i'm going to tommy pope's house
yeah it's a good hang too though he's
pretty trashy
visually classy gang we could not be
more excited to have our incredibly
special guest back with us again today
he is one of the funniest stand-up
comedians working he is also an author
of this book right here running the
light you know him you love him give it
up for the one the only sam talent
hey thanks for having me back guys that
was great that's also the first hoodie
joke you've laughed at all year me yeah
uh he got me recently
see he know i'm a big flat anything what
are you my manager
this is my boss god damn it
[ __ ] the quarterly reviews are coming
up and you're reminding him that i stink
no i watch the show and you'll have this
great bit you come in real hot and then
kevin's like just checking his watch
what time did we start if i could sit
next to lauren michaels over here
[ __ ] ice at me very good age good
work
he's just checking the patreon number
yeah we're just going to still need them
two three more months yeah
you just bought yourself another day
yeah
looking for a job accident yeah there
you go tommy's killing it man shout out
to stubby and that's special
um last time we saw you we hung out we
had a nice time
it seems to me unless i'm wrong here on
the timetable that
you really started cooking
sometime after that you started going
under you started going on the road more
and then i saw you're in europe for
extended periods and i'm not talking
about with you and timmy d yeah yeah you
were over there with your squad i went
over brought the whole family to europe
for three weeks over christmas yeah
that's what t-bone's talking about you
i look at you and it seems to me that
you don't let any of the trappings or of
success yeah
yeah i'm just avoiding it at all
[Laughter]
no of like
of like a city comic where it's like
you're worried about this you you look
you you live out of you in your space
you have you you have a life outside of
comedy that a lot of people don't have
yeah yeah and you're and you're enjoying
that and flourishing in that to such a
degree that it makes me happy to say oh
it's really sweet man it's awesome yeah
uh mortality is a big thing i i deal
with okay i'm pretty sure i have a
comedy podcast well you know but let's
be honest i probably got 15 good more
years oh yeah
yeah so i'm trying to get it all in
i'm trying to get through the weekend
yeah this guy's talking 15 years his
fingers crossed i didn't even pay my
taxes
yeah man it's fun i like to live uh you
know i like to drink nice wine i like to
be in the water you know were you
already i'm sorry kevin were you already
going out with with tim dillon on the
road
no no that started afterwards that
started around yeah yeah right i think i
was out here last summer and i started
going out with him in september okay and
then then you took a little bit of time
off and you guys all went to [ __ ]
europe yeah yeah yeah uh-huh it was uh
it was a hoot and a holler we spread my
mom's ashes in like three different
rivers [ __ ] awesome yeah we're still
looking for a killer
oh that's book two
right there yeah she died on september
11th last year jesus i'm sorry to hear
that easy to remember yeah yeah uh-huh
man so uh yeah after that like i i
really realized there's not a lot of
time that we have so it's like let's
blow all the cash we're not having kids
sure you know my wife i got life
insurance so when i go down she's fine
that's real dirtbag [ __ ] well she's
she's a term life you're almost trying
to die yeah i want i want to tap out so
she still has you know a couple good
more years to get some sweet new hogs
she's a hard-working young doctor with
rocking cans like you know i'll leave
her a million bucks she's good there you
go she's a doctor so she does well on
her own anyway yeah i know you think she
would uh be more invested in how i'm
living
she's got that millie staring at her
oh yeah she's like have more butter
you quit smoking why
protein shakes taste good what is it
sugar
but even the stuff that you could do at
home
with the skill the little cookouts and
all that stuff and you guys were just at
like a state fair yeah and you do that
kind of stuff and i [ __ ] love it
was there an influx
of cash around like sometime after we
met for the first time no no i've always
been very smart with my money and the
book was like it was life-changing cash
money yeah yeah
so you know we bought the bronco
i gave my sister an ethereum for her
wedding what's that it's a whole it's
like a like a mini [ __ ] it's like a big
it's a yeah it's a coin yeah it's like
the silver to bitcoin's gold how much
are they a piece they were like four
grand yeah i dropped one on her little
ass nice that's the wedding present yeah
that's the wedding present how do you
give that that's huge you uh just tell
her she has one yeah you're like i'll
just make it up yeah
i owe you one ethereum
the next day just crashed no it did dude
did it yeah i gave it her wedding was
like end of april and it was like right
around 3 500 bucks and now they're down
to like a thousand
so she's like maybe i could have got two
that well it's the same difference to
you yeah you know she's a greedy little
monster
oh yeah i take her to europe
then she's pissed she's not going to
japan with me and my wife in january you
can't win how old is she
uh 32 oh yeah is she out there in the
same neck of the woods yeah she's in
denver so she's in your life on the on
the daily oh yeah nice too much some
would say yeah yeah i see a lot of old
fee once i go to japan yeah and my
wife's like no this is for us i want to
have sex and spas and my sister's like
we'll give you space
i don't want my sister smelling what i
do in japan
those rooms out there are small they're
so little i know yeah i'm trying to bang
my wife behind a paper
sheet i just see i just see the
silhouette on a tiny little bed i'm just
bowing at my wife's vagina
oh when you say some you were always
smart with money uh yeah well no i
didn't have money for a long time i was
like destitute forever well when you
were younger did you were you the kind
of kid that like you know if he kind of
cut a lawn he put ten dollars away and
all that stuff oh yeah i was i was so
industrious i was out cutting lawns
what are you talking about that's crazy
i had to bring back up clothes here
because i sweat through my first shirt i
took a cab
[Laughter]
kind of real warren buffett story yeah
i also eat mcdonald's every day
you said you were smart with money i
don't know no yeah i was always good
with money but i didn't have any so it's
really easy to be like i have twenty
dollars till thursday sure
hold on is that budgeted or is that all
you got because if kevin says no he's
twenty dollars no literally like no
money like the only money i had for
years was hosting the open mic monday
and tuesday in denver and that was a
total of like 180 bucks and then i could
scrape together cash on the weekends
working but it was also like okay i'm
still gonna smoke name brand cigarettes
i'm still gonna spend like a bunch of
money on every miller light that hear
you just learn how to be like all right
you can make like you said you can make
20 bucks stretch until you get paid
again whether it's all right let me get
my sigs i'll do i can get five bucks
here a couple beers over there and
figure it out yeah i mean we had to do
that yeah no listen i know we're dirt
bags but he from what he said that he
was smart with money i thought it was a
situation he's just applying that now
all right i have more money but i still
live like you know because i used to
hate in high school when like you would
take a test and then you lean over like
the girl next to me like i definitely
failed then she like i definitely failed
it too yeah she gets like an a-plus
right it's like there's people that say
they're broke and meanwhile they got
like 10 grand in the bank right they're
just smart and they don't even consider
that as money no yeah i mean i have it's
mostly invested and stuff my liquid
assets are pretty low with assets yeah
[ __ ] well yeah man how you write one
best-selling novel in your life this
next one might be [ __ ] who knows so i'm
trying to save and nut up all this money
stock and fanta oh yeah yeah i bought so
much crystal pepsi stuff
i'm boned y'all
hoping jaritos makes a real run
it was so funny on the louis episode
where you brought up haritos and he was
like no i'm talking about good sodas
yeah toss that yeah it's wild it's good
it's nice to be here this is your third
secret mexican guest you've had in a row
you're also yeah yeah uh did we not
cover that i think we probably did my
grandma was a little cave mexican from
northern new mexico oh your grandma's
100 yeah mexican uh-huh that's awesome
and i'm like my dad keeps saying
9 16.
because my grandpa on his side claimed
to be like his great-grandpa married
like a cherokee princess okay i don't
think there's like a royalty hierarchy
in the cherokee tribes you don't casino
money coming no [ __ ] though it'd be nice
yeah it'd be great i wouldn't be here
you know how likely i would be yeah
shout out to the seneca casino by the
way
up there in buffalo oh yeah threw a
couple chips down a couple things with
uncle hank's way i got fleeced yeah what
happened with the 10k bed
uh it's public knowledge we lost i know
but how did it feel uh it felt horrible
you remember his name
you're not that far
and manny you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
i know what you were doing down here
[Laughter]
you remembered his name
oh my god it's not a sicilian vendetta
i saw that happening and couldn't
process it like i couldn't get it out it
was so funny
no akash came down with us he was
supposed to match the bet
gets in the car [ __ ] you know he
doesn't have the money he gets all
turned around but he's a rich guy so we
assume that he knows what he's doing
he's like when we get down there i'll
take the money out at the counter i'm
like i don't know he's got an american
express card i don't know how these
people [ __ ] operate and it turned
into a whole [ __ ] song
okay people with money
people that do well
and um yeah he got all jammed up with
customer service at american express
they wouldn't take this and just all the
mojo just went we lost we did we walked
in there like we [ __ ] owned the place
yeah and then it was 40 minutes later me
and him are just
smoking cigarettes next to an ashtray
waiting for akash to get the money but
how free did you feel after you lost
that money no horrible
donuts and got a doughnut that's no hard
huh yeah because i've i've just gone
like that lost a lot of money gambling
really i didn't know that oh yeah poison
sports uh oh i have sports gambling for
sure especially in colorado because you
can just do it on your phone
i'm like uh i'm down significantly in
sports gambling uh there's no wins there
long term so much for the liquid assets
huh yeah that's why i can't have any
liquid it's all got to be soft [ __ ]
cleveland screwing me yeah uh but then
uh blackjack when i lived in vegas
blackjack was a big one
yeah i've been so stupid with money i
was in vegas one time my mom's birthday
was november 17th all on black november
17th it hit 17. i let it right again it
hits two in a row always let it rise two
in a row seventeen back to back to back
or back to back
yes roulette really i left it again
all gone holy [ __ ] yeah that first hit
wasn't good enough the second hit wasn't
good enough it's the loss that i think
that i i covet and crave i just fought i
just [ __ ] said that two weeks ago i
was like i'm in it for the loss i'm in
it that's the only time i feel
okay it's like a baptismal yes because
you're totally like you know i'm i'm i'm
i can't control myself it's all gone i'm
free because if i still had the money
you'd be spending it yeah the brand the
wheels would be spending on how to
either double it or spend it or what do
i buy or if you have no money you're
like just kidding my package but also
how to hide it oh you know what i mean
yeah these guys are cowboy out here well
hey man
the irs doesn't need to know what i'm
doing
same here folks and also it's like
things are not going well societal
i came home last weekend from the road
my wife was like i signed us up for
tactical shotgun classes all right i was
like what this is what you're doing
alone in the house considering this kind
of [ __ ] sure that's pretty crazy yeah
you got weapon you got steel come on it
was in colorado
hey man i'm from the west yeah where it
always looks like rain
i'm from the salt flats baby
i keep that thing on me i like that yeah
having a shotgun is fun
i know i wanted i wanted to get one
when i turned like 18 or 19 or whatever
and i moved out to well it was the 60s
it was a different time
but uh i just never did we weren't gun
people really growing up yeah not gun
people bb gun my dad
had a red rider take a raccoon not every
once in a while that's about it though i
was never a gun person growing up my
grandfather used to keep a pistol in his
truck but that was about it
yeah it was just because he had ptsd
from various wars they didn't have them
they had like a rifle or something in
the house right in case a coyote or
something came through uh yeah my
grandpa had a rifle but he would never
brandish it wildly but that pistol got
pulled in the sonic drive-through
the sonic drive oh yeah
chili fries are pretty good oh dude when
they screw up the ratio of the slushie
to the ice cream grandpa's firing off a
couple warning shots
it's a flare gun calm down you look here
akash
we were talking the other night about
you getting to go to australia yeah and
i was like did you see any terrifying
animals deadly animal creatures you're
like no i was like what's the cutest
animal you saw in australia uh not the
koalas the koalas reek they smell yeah
they look real cute they have a sex
gland on their chest the male koalas all
right and they're not supposed to hold
them after they've hit like puberty but
we went to a real rinky-dink koala farm
so this guy just reeked
yeah he stunk it up and then you hold
them on your chest so then after you
leave you just smell like you know don't
know all the koala chicks hanging all
over you at the bars and [ __ ] then after
that because you know
you're burying the leaf it up at the
corner yeah
yeah i got i got a couple of unique
strains of chlamydia coming back
[ __ ] patient zero over here yeah
koala pox coming in i think the uh the
red kangaroo was the cutest because i
was there with ben avery who has some
kind of like tiny adorable animal autism
like all he sends is like lilo and
stitch gifts back and forth because he
loves those so much so yeah he was like
he is a sweet sweet boy he's adorable
and innocent yeah no he really is it's
funny to be there with him and tim
because tim's very upset he can't get a
club sandwich in the dane tree
rainforest at 4am
i mean what do you got to do yeah this
place is bad you're out of are you are
you out of here are you out of leona's
potatoes yeah i don't understand it's
very funny to be in a world heritage
site and it's the only place in the
world the rainforest all this rainforest
in the world and then also the great
barrier reef and they have butt right
there and tim's like
can't get cigarettes at the resort
it's like well why don't you just you
know go on a walk walk why
i get a porsche bushes are good you
drive around
that's why tim impression is just say
something and then say it again that's
pretty good one more time
how did you feel about all that stuff
being in that rainforest it was life it
was it was otherworldly did you go
swimming in the great barrier reef are
there sharks in there there's these tiny
like as big as your thumbnail jellyfish
that are called like the the terror fish
because they just fill you with the
sense of dread if they bite you what
yeah yeah i think he's been getting bit
every day for [ __ ] 30 years yeah
this jellyfish what are they brainiac
that's crazy
that that's nuts yeah dude
you're like did i leave the stove on
what's happening yeah
i know i'm trying to take the welt yeah
it just feels like your mom's calling
you late at night for three days holy
[ __ ] yeah
holy
i think my checking account's overdrawn
that's nuts yeah so i mean it wasn't we
didn't like
immerse ourselves past the genitals but
it was definitely like i got to put my
feet into this ocean right here
yeah and then tim's like you know chain
smoking on the beach there's no one else
at the beach he's just like
well
all right back to the car
i heard there's ice cream eight and a
half hours away
to the chopper boys
uh shout out to timmy d he's the
greatest he does it right no one lives
like tim and that's where i got the
whole thing about like i'm i'm not
having kids you know everything's taking
cause that's what tim will say all the
time he's like all the money goes to ben
i have kids i don't i'm not having kids
who cares i could live or die everyone
will remember me you know
he's the best he's great the most
generous guy i've ever worked with and
initially when i was with him it was
like i'm a hired employee and now it's
like i love the guy you know that was a
fun transition to have happen that's
awesome you guys have been kicking
around doing your thing man we love to
see it yeah man i had lunch with him
yesterday and uh oh that's right he's in
town yeah right i forgot yeah he's doing
his thing i didn't know there were so
many preparations of lobster
really yeah i just he orders for the
table i i i picked the restaurant
twice
and it was dog [ __ ] and it was the most
embarrassing thing wow
petrified yeah we were out together for
like 10 months so every now and then i'm
like tim i did some research and he's
like okay let's see what you got kid
there's a group i want you to fail oh
yeah no he does a little bit yeah i mean
again
[Laughter]
did you try to beat him in order for the
table at your restaurants no of course
not number fours yeah
i want them smothered covered and capped
hey whatever the boys want yeah kev
let's talk about that bespoke post box
of awesome that's exactly what it called
box awesome comes to your house every
month gang it's the summer time you want
to be outdoors you want to be grilling
you want to be smelling fresh you want
to be looking for you want to have cool
stuff it's cool you guys ship the
[ __ ] you want to have cool stuff get
the box of awesome every month delivered
to your house they pair up with small
businesses they pair up with emerging
brands to bring you a unique experience
yeah guys got camping gear essentials
beach day travel must-haves i got a
duffel that i use and i travel around
with real cool to get started take the
quiz at box of awesome.com your answers
will help them pick the right box of
awesome for you they release new boxes
every month across a ton of different
categories each box is valued around 70
dollars but you only pay a frag
like the big man said you're supporting
small business ninety percent of the
stuff that comes in a box of awesome uh
is from a small up-and-coming brazilian
i don't know why i said brizand it's
free to sign up you can skip a month at
any time or cancel call to action baby
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome dot com
enter code garbage at checkout that's
box of awesome dot com code garbage for
20 off your first box box of awesome dot
com promo code garbage debt let's talk
about dave dave dave dave dave dave i
ain't talking about one of the bozos you
grew up with i'm talking about the dave
app uh-huh you've been strapped for cash
have i i'm stressed right now what are
you talking about
dave
get dave on a horn hemmed up all of a
sudden things pop up every month he got
this bill you got that bill something
happens in the car it'd be nice
to have a little bit of cash
on hand a little bit of a band-aid yes
and the dave app can help you do that
yes
if you're living paycheck to paycheck or
struggling to make ends meet can be very
stressful when unexpected expenses come
up now dave can help you get out of a
pinch in any way you need dave is a
banking app that can help you get up to
500 instantly with extra cash that's
more money to fill your bank for to buy
a wedding gift to catch up on bills sure
got a hot date or a show at the track
whenever you want it so
you can finally tackle those expensive
that have been stressing you without any
hang-ups there's no interest and no
credit check needed
millions of people have already
downloaded the dave app to get financial
relief they need with extra cash so if
you're in a pinch need some help
download the dave app and uh
use it as a helping hand
from future you download the dave app
d-a-v-e sign up for extra cash account
and get up to 500 instantly for terms
and conditions go to dave.com legal
instant transfer fees apply banking
provided by evolve men member fdic
future you will thank you do it yeah but
yeah he's a big milkshake guy big
milkshake guy what about what tell me
about these lobsters
what's going on here oh there was like a
was it thermador there was a there was a
chilled preparation there was like some
kind of like almost like a ceviche
yeah i'm just sitting there eating and
tim will have like three bites of
something then be over it you know
that's a very rich guy thing to do
i'll take it from here tim
wrapping up the shells yeah
you put these in the blender for about
two minutes
oh my god buddy good to have you here
good to see you so glad to be here man
let's do a couple of cues from the old
patreon by the way i want to shout out
to to the fan base for being so kind and
supportive uh the garbage heads the best
have been great
but it is funny when they'll like come
to a show and there'll be someone there
who doesn't know me and they'll be like
this is sam talent he's a [ __ ] pig
he's disgusting oh my god this guy's the
king of trash mountain
very nice to meet you his bedroom janet
and then they're also like you and tom
takara you gotta go head to head you
gotta have a trash off and i'm like why
and they're like well he's more trash
than you and automatically i'm like no
i'm the worst
i'm the one who's gross you just [ __ ]
your pants right there
you put them on my head
that's like [ __ ] homelander and
soldier boy [ __ ] coming that's bad
yikes i'm also so sweaty what's going on
in here
[Laughter]
sweat adds to the garbage it's like it's
a deposition
it gets real soupy in here oh yeah it's
like a rainforest exhibit i'm getting
grilled by liz cheney over here let's go
as far as the prepper thing before
before we get into she's talking about
the tactical uh tactical firearm classes
yeah would you be a guy to like bury
gold or something like that because the
cash ain't gonna be worth anything when
it all goes south yeah especially when
it comes to like stocks and digital
assets sure um i there's a certain
holding i have in silver
really um but yeah do you have access to
it uh yeah i mean you have to strongly
someone else doesn't have a key and i
have to find him
there's not an amulet i broke in half
that unlocks a lock box nick cage isn't
involved yeah no it's just in a it's in
a safe in a remote location that's
awesome yeah but again bullets and salt
that's what you invest in really yeah i
mean when it all goes down you're gonna
need bullets you're gonna need salt why
salt because salt you can use to uh
preserve food french fries
yeah exactly yeah don't you want to rim
the glass of your margarita i mean
i heard you want to live like an animal
yeah come on are we doing this are we
doing it yeah the sun might have
exploded but i'm still trying to live
baby are you standing in front of the
chinese overlord
hey you see that yeah it's mr yam
[Laughter]
you boys milked me for too long
it's time for my piece
of flesh yeah so i know salt back in the
day was that was like current that was
currency
yeah
johnny's history over here yeah
[Laughter]
i wish i had a treat i could give you
yeah
very good hey
i think i learned that from elton brand
to be honest with you
[Applause]
there's the camera in the oven that's
what i'm talking about yeah alton brown
he was great yeah he knows all that [ __ ]
good eats good eats yeah yeah i heard
he's a dream to work with really
[Laughter]
got a little showbiz talk for you folks
man
guys
[Laughter]
having you here feels like the last day
of school that's what's awesome about it
oh i'm giddy dude it's the summer i feel
like we're getting ready to get out of
here special treat because i do like
when our friends uh like are the guests
who we didn't know and then we've become
friends we're friends with through the
show well they live in the west coast or
elsewhere when they come to the city
when they come to town it's like it's
like an appointment oh it's so great i'm
like excited yeah i came in a couple
days early
uh
well we can talk about it in a second
let's get to some questions please
subscribe i have a question for you guys
in a minute i was i was gonna how much
salt do you think i need
i'm talking about here you're probably
going to want like to get like two
big blocks of salt like a salt lick that
horses use but you want to make sure
that it's iodized salt really no yeah
it's that himalayan stuff's going out
the window that pink shit's worthless
yeah when the bullets start flying yeah
when people are trading their holes for
food yeah
you want the good shape yeah when all my
teeth are knocked out you know and i'm
just on all fours
getting attached to the human centipede
yeah exactly
all right there you go salt and bullets
baby i like it that's pretty good salt
and bullets uh as you know when you sign
up for that there patreon the greatest
goddamn website of all time we can uh
we'll answer your garbage question on
the air it's just the best way to do it
patreon gets the first crick in it yes
sir uh this one's from leslie uh have
you ever cut off the funeral possession
because you were late for work and
needed to get there have you ever caught
up cut off a funeral process that's a
real piece of [ __ ] move oh yeah that's
dastardly yeah talk about not respecting
the dead yeah yeah just because you got
to get to denny's or whatever you're
doing that's like something bad's gonna
happen uh-huh yeah that's bad juju i've
never been late to a job because i
haven't had a job since i was like 19.
so no what was the last job ice cream
truck driver whoa
how many people you kill huh well the
greek mob runs well allegedly runs the
the ice cream truck rack no i need
either shotgun skills yeah yeah i don't
know if they're greek but they're
swarthy all right they're tommy pope
adjacent okay um so yeah they run and if
you get there early enough they give you
a truck and then you get paid in cash so
i would just go home every day with like
130 in quarters like in a sock
it was a pretty good gig i'd pick up my
buddy bonzo we'd rip around smoke blunts
nice ice down beers in the cooler cool
yeah cause you're just driving like four
miles an hour eight hours a day sure so
you can be a little turnt you know yeah
yeah
exactly flies itself yeah i'm not
getting on the highway here yeah you
just put on the autopilot driving on the
highway in a doorless ice cream truck
feels good it's like going to the moon
yeah fresh bomb pop in your hand dude
future's in front of you
you have no idea how many of those
spongebob pops are oh i love them yeah
he'd just be like i don't need to stop
and get food i'll have six more
spidermen
poor choco tacos how to do it oh choco
taco you leave it on the dash for about
a half an hour yeah choco taco was like
that was like the
the [ __ ] holy grail to me as a kid i
remember when they came out we weren't
allowed to get them because they were
like 50 cents more than everything else
on the ice cream truck they came in that
silver space age packet yeah
i've said it before but for the longest
time i thought there was taco meat in
there
that i didn't touch my brother would get
them i'm like [ __ ] that dude give me a
firecracker
i thought the elton brand thing was
going to be the dumbest thing
i was seven he's 46.
and brother we got plenty more
along those lines i thought that pizza
hut was pizza hot until i was 22. oh
okay yeah so i'm right there with you
dude
yeah
but yeah never cut off a funeral
procession nah never do that's it's [ __ ]
it's f i i like i get so much anxiety
being in them yeah especially when
you're driving it's like it's like the
last chopper at a nominee they're gonna
leave you
sometimes you get real panicky you're
looking to see how far it goes back
making sure everybody's sticking
together and if you have something in
front of me that really needs a [ __ ]
heater after a [ __ ] emotional service
if you're trying to get to the [ __ ]
cemetery so she can rip one before the
casket rolls in she'll [ __ ] blow your
doors off i forget who it was it was
either my mom or my aunt patty got stuck
in one and like they weren't in it they
were just driving and ended up in the
like line of cars at the luncheon and
they didn't want to get out because it's
like disrespectful to the dead
[Laughter]
yeah in a rag top jeep
they were going to the beach
surfboard hanging out the back yeah
sunscreen on the nose wham's playing
yeah
i've been in a funeral procession where
at least five of the vehicles were
riding lawn mowers or tractors whoa
yeah that's uh the country that i came
up in holy [ __ ] [ __ ] nuts man you
ever been the one that has a police
escort that's pretty sweet no because
the only ones i've been in i've never
been in one in a big city okay so i've
only been in one in like cities with
population less than a thousand yeah no
knees well he's usually he's attending
the funeral probably you know because
it's all yeah
out there where the tractors and john
deere
uh tractor tractors are like you know
cut the backyard tractor no like there's
been some like actual like agricultural
machinery involved um i don't know
coming down the street yeah yeah an
excavator
someone's in a steamroller
[Laughter]
hurry up steve [ __ ]
bobcats everyone's crying
you ever seen a man weep in a bobcat
he's shaking
looks like the constructicons got
whacked
a good time
great question this one's from the
milkman of the midwest is a garbage to
collect your family's old antibiotics in
case you need one because you don't have
insurance no no that's real big i mean
antibiotics i think in most families get
passed around 100 yeah at least most
blue collar fat everybody i know passes
them around like they're [ __ ] tic
tacs oh yeah i was always taught to just
take a round of antibiotics every once
in a while what yeah yeah
i mean there might be some sort of issue
no
my mom was you know if it's coming up in
like cold and flu season or whatever
yeah i remember at one point she had a
z-pack connect you're getting a hands-on
get your hands on a z-pack
fellas hit me up my wife's got this
she's a doctor man that's what i do to
anybody who works in the middle it's
like it was just pained and out pills in
my family it was like [ __ ] a pharmacy
not like even not pills pills but like
you know [ __ ] like that antibiotics
[ __ ] this yeah they jammed up call
somebody they got it and also you should
hoard through antibiotics too for when
society collapses
yeah well yeah if you're just randomly
having some antibiotics because your mom
was a witch doctor you pass me some
penicillin
i think crazy is the word
[Laughter]
um
[ __ ] anybody you can get around that
though doesn't don't doesn't that [ __ ]
grow on oranges or something uh there's
there's some kind of like fungus or mold
that but you would have to
cultivate it in a way that i don't think
you could do just like in the bush based
on my own brand comments yeah
if you slam dunk this mold maybe yeah
[ __ ] i got that salt antibiotics and
bullets uh-huh all right yeah i gotta
get a piece and these are just for
bartering too sure there's a number of
things that you're gonna want to need in
your bunker that
are edible that'd be good booby traps
booby traps yeah bunch of paint cans on
ropes sure do you have like uh
in case something does do you know do
you have a a route of where you're gonna
go cause you're probably already
you're not in denver probably in the
city like
this is where i'm gonna go go up in the
hills or something let's either drive
north to wyoming or try and make it out
to my dad's property in the country
depending where i'm at and that's like
we have a bronco with the the off-road
sport mode and that's like secretly the
ace up my sleeve is we got to bug out
without being on the highway yeah got a
little nas you know what i'm saying oh
yeah
they say that if
[ __ ] ever really went down
that that denver kind of would be
the last stand that would be like the uh
wherever they went in lord of the rings
in the second one yeah with helms deep
that would be the helms deep yeah well
yeah bowl there in the in the book the
stand they all want to bowl there oh
okay just because like i think there's
an elevation situation elevation
mountains yeah in the center yeah
yeah that's where the [ __ ] would go down
but i mean honestly if [ __ ] goes down
goodbye yeah i don't want to pop every
perkis that i can find
[Laughter]
go sweetly into that good night hey just
go out scratching you know what i mean
yeah what am i like i'm in the front
lines of rebuilding society what are we
[ __ ] talking about i'm sweating in
here
i know i don't know my next season for
two days i'm [ __ ] miserable yeah i'm
dehydrated now
there's a case of salt under the sink
yeah
later baby
i hope i hope they honor that insurance
policy
the new alien overlords take [ __ ]
geico yeah
uh this one's from 100 grass-fed queef
first time long time is it garbage if
your family sings happy birthday to
jesus on christmas including a cake with
candles oh
that's [ __ ] crazy whoa what's that
those are the first ones that'll be
eating your brains when it comes oh yeah
well it's probably easy in this family
because uh your dad's eight wives are a
great chorus you are they are yeah
they're really harmonized sounds like
the commodores in there yeah
yeah happy birthday
for some reason they do the black
version doing the downbeats and whatever
yeah
that's what i'm talking about
um yeah that's uh i i wonder what that
is that's it's mental illness sure yeah
yeah plus i feel like
he wouldn't want that he wouldn't want
that cheesy happy birthday [ __ ] like
just think we get embarrassed by that
stuff he probably doesn't get it
now you know what i mean
i think christmas is more classy he
would hate it i don't know yeah he's got
all those [ __ ] killer songs all those
bing crosby songs
he don't want that post you come at me
with happy birthday yeah you [ __ ] you're
okay
you're opening up a silent night and
you're going in a happy birthday what
are we doing here
i respect the move you can also hit him
with four on the floor gospel you know
like you have every religious song that
would be apt for him as well true yeah
yeah you have all that catalogue and no
one's wishing my goddamn happy birthday
but this sweet sweet family that's what
i'm saying everybody says merry
christmas nobody says happy birthday i
would even have more respect for it if
they weren't like the uh the casual
dining route where they you know they
can't sing happy birthday because if
they did happy yeah something like that
i think that's true yeah i don't like to
do it a copyright yeah that's why every
chili's and applebee's has their own
version of the birthday that becomes a
copyright yeah happy happy birthday it's
your big day the actual happy birthday
song is one of the most expensive songs
to use in movie and film and i know i'm
aware but that's what i'm saying it's
not being recorded anywhere so you're
not allowed to sing it there's a lot of
bootlegs of like red robin birthday
songs out there but that can't be the
reason
because of the cop but it's not i'm
saying it's not getting like if you go
to folk at [ __ ] tulsa oklahoma and
somebody sings happy birthday
you don't owe the happy birthday people
in nick i worked i worked at a friday's
and every time we sung the jewish zombie
birthday song we had to send an amp
stamp an appetizer sampler
i had two quarts of jack daniels
you would never be able to sing any song
ever that doesn't make any sense i know
it is the some woman held it or
something toby are you looking it up
yeah it's exactly what we're saying the
happy birthday song was
still uh oh no it's it the the the
public domain hit oh really yeah yeah
it's on three they can do it yeah let's
blast it quick
juice it up
before jay-z scoops it up yeah
kevin let's talk about sheath sheath
baby i got them on right now they just
sent me right now a huge shipment of
them listen staple in the comedy podcast
world that she's underwear the ceo is a
huge comedy fan good guy madame's
gangfest shout out to rob solid dude
makes a solid quality pair of undies so
your balls don't stick together you got
breathable fabric feel good feel
confident down there i got it and he's a
goddamn veteran i got them all right now
my balls are in a one pound my dick is
over there
uh
the idea for sheath came from its
founder us army soldier robert patton
during his second tour and iraq baby
support this awesome veteran
veteran-owned company and support two
tours not one tour you went back in this
[ __ ] yeah uh so you go to sheath
underwear dot com use code garbage for
20 off your first order with sheaths
underwear 100 money-back guarantee
there's no risk in giving them a shot
they're good guys listen
stop wearing old underwear stop wearing
cotton underwear like a bozo bozos these
are great they don't smell you can wear
them for two three days in a row and
ain't no must on them you know what i
mean
uh sheath underwear dot com promo code
garbage get youth underwear and let them
support your balls do it baby
now back to the show
no yeah that's uh that's disturbing
behavior which was described in this
question yeah that's crazy birthday cake
on listen
we know the reality the situation here
all right i'm not kicking a piece of
cake out of bed yeah cake's not making
it out of the car no but a piece of cake
on christmas wouldn't
feel right
a cake on christmas is weird to me what
yeah who has cake you draw the oddest
lines in the sand that's just it's wild
i could do it the next day i couldn't
have like a like a betty crocker cake
with icing what do you what would you
what's better i mean you do the you have
manicotti
[Laughter]
throw the sparkler in the gnocchi
and hit it
no uh you know pumpkin pie apple pie huh
like little but i think there's a
chocolate cake there it's not whatever
because they're gonna just look weird
but that would look out of place if it
was a nice christmas spread and then a
[ __ ]
happy birthday jesus [ __ ] cake well i
think you have to separate the two
holidays in your head yeah because
there's christmas and then there's also
a birthday party going on yeah so when
once we're trying to force one in on
christmas it's not it's two separate
entities it's not an amalgamation it's
two things maybe if we did it a separate
house that's christmas at my
grandmother's and then we all left had
coffee dessert there and then went at
another second round at my aunt and if
anyone mentions christmas at your aunt's
house you go on we change we go home and
change make our aunt leave early so she
could take all the christmas decorations
down maybe throw up some [ __ ]
balloons yeah
all right i'll do it
it's not jesus's birthday unless your
aunt is heavily inconvenienced on
christmas yeah yeah so never make
another full dinner i will just throw it
out yeah
that's what he would have wanted
i think that's a family guy yeah going
out to dinner he's like i want you to
cook anyway i don't want you getting
rusty
[Laughter]
all right this one's from ryan have you
ever had a set time of the night where
indoor smoking was allowed
so like i guess if you're hanging out at
a house party or a house and you're like
all right it's one in the morning after
dinner we're allowed to have sex like
night and weekend minutes exactly
exactly like hey you know it's like
international waters after 2 a.m if
you're up doing lines or something
you can smoke cigs inside
the purge of ripping burnies late night
cigs inside for me and like our kyle
wherever always had to be in the kitchen
because it was like no couch there was
no like fabric to absorb this smoke
all over the [ __ ] stove it was always
the last of the mohicans too it was the
last six guys hanging out yeah the
homeowner's asleep yeah so you're like
well he's not gonna know
wake up in the morning cook some popcorn
call it a [ __ ] day i remember as a
kid i can i can picture that you come
down all the lights at her in the house
you smell that faint smoke you hear the
laughter you hear the talking of the
adults and this and that you're an aunt
or whatever and it's just that light
coming out of the kitchen you come in
there and they're like what are you
doing
a couple smooches yeah they want you to
dance around yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah all of a sudden i'm knee deep
in a crazy eddy impersonation
trying to do crowd work
hey so uncle steve's here looks like
that biopsy didn't stop you
let's keep it going for the weight today
you're wearing a fedora
you're completely nude otherwise
you're a little eight-year-old peen
uh yeah it was always when people were
tripping because everyone would get
drunk at the party and go to bed those
people would pass out and the people who
took hallucinogens would still be up and
either outside smoking or inside smoking
uh so yeah i think that it was more it
wasn't time dependent it was more
substance dependent for us sure and
every house i lived in before i moved in
with my wife was six 24 7. really oh we
were just blasting we were kind of still
kind of my places were similar too yeah
cause it's like i know we're not getting
this security deposit back no matter
what put smoke in here let's paint the
walls let's put holes and stuff yeah it
is nice though to keep that separation
of church and state right within the
home you know what i mean you go out you
have one it gives you something to do
you go out on the porch because it's
already gross if you're just sitting
there
playing manhunt smoking cigarettes on
the couch scraping resin when you're not
playing like that's a gross dark time
and without some kind of air flow it oh
dude it's stagnant yeah it gets brutal
gets in your hair yeah and then you wake
up the next morning you're like ugh
i don't really want to shower but i
guess i have to yeah 100 and anything
smells in there smoking in the shower
though
cold one in the shower blasting a hundo
doesn't get better man yeah like if i if
i could pick my last 30 minutes on earth
i was just going to say that's something
to do the day you're dying yeah that's
right before the bank job yeah because
you're [ __ ] trying to file
it with a grill lighter too oh for sure
yeah
or that's no big yeah it's off the stove
and then run to the bathroom
yeah
that's the movie i love a sig off of
stone i thought i was worse i've been
off the bernies but that is
dude my house at temple university had
an electric stove and we would [ __ ]
lighten cigs off an electric stove was
so [ __ ] good there's that
anticipation it has to heat up uh-huh
and you get that
it's a little bit of a damage if you get
greedy and jump the gun it [ __ ]
catches it oh yeah stuck yeah you're
that idiot you ripped half your
cigarette off like a [ __ ] fool you
gotta go bum one again
hey man i'm real sorry we all used to
smoke camels and uh if you didn't have
any cigarettes you had to wait until the
camel walked on fire which is when the
feet of the camel at the bottom of the
cig then you could have it from someone
whoa what would you guys call that we
called it kills like hey could i get
kills on let me get the heroine on that
the hair yeah that's where all the
nicotine is man it's all resonated so
let me let me get the heroin on that
right kills is also ascendant we did
kills we did i think shorts was one let
me get shorts on that kill shorts camel
walks on fire we called them counties
counties yeah because it's how they
would smoke cigs in county it's like
i'll take anything yeah yeah yeah yeah
damn did you really call him that or do
you see that in a movie totally yeah no
that was the homies hey we all saw the
wire all right yeah
because you and dustin dolan
that's a deep cut for the kids hell yeah
man baker
i'm reading the book this weekend and
i'm getting off from this this week i'm
making a strong i'm making let me say
this making a strong effort too good
yeah yeah right it's too much but until
then i got to pack in the bag got a
bunch of heaters well the book says you
can smoke while you're while you're
reading it by reading
and it worked for you
yeah this is heavily debated it worked
twice for me yeah
i quit for five years after 15 years i
quit for five years and then i picked it
back up during the pandemic
and then uh
i read it and i stopped again in a day
and it's been three weeks and now you're
lording it over everybody
no he's going around like a mormon you
kidding me yeah knocking on doors yeah
he's singing happy birthday to jesus on
christmas with great lung capacity by
the way
i'm hitting behind
[Laughter]
good [ __ ] i love an indoor bernie though
all right i'm getting me all get me all
juiced up over here
uh let's see
this is from sean have you or anyone you
know ever bought meat from a couple of
guys driving around town with a deep
freeze full of all cuts of beef in it
sure 100 sure i feel like out by you
that might be a little bit more
legitimate yeah usually you know it's
like from the rogers farm or the evans
farm but in denver they have those dudes
driving around and sometimes they're not
even driving around they're just on a
bicycle with a cooler in the back
yeah oh yeah eggs bacon
beef yeah but it's real deal [ __ ] see
that happens in new york a lot a van
will pull up yeah and two dirt balls
will be like hey you want any steaks you
need steaks for the weekend they're
stolen or they're old that's okay i
don't care where it comes from but they
might be old you don't worry about their
food safety make stroganoff huh you know
make a little stew make a beef bougail
what overcook it yeah cook it to [ __ ]
and whine it's fine
wait a minute then hold on a second that
opens up a real bad door
have you cooked with meat you knew was
bad
and just cooked the [ __ ] out of it so
it's tough
yes
yes yeah because of all the memory loss
from the botulism yeah
i'm sure you're having trouble piecing
it together
hold on where am i uh it was a whole
week of the fall well i have one of
those uh those legs like i have an
iberico ham that i get every year at
christmas which is the spanish ham it's
kind of like a country ham where they
let it like hang in a cellar and the
outside of it rots well it looks like
prosciutto a little kind of like
prosciutto but there's a there's a
protective mold on the outside so it's
really hard to know once you get deep
into that thing
just how rotten the innards are
and i definitely cook with that a lot
hold on
define innards it's a p it's a solid
piece of muscle it's a whole leg right
but once you know i get it on christmas
and when you get to the fourth of july
like right around now what are you
talking about you leave it out you leave
it out on a shelf yeah and it has like a
stand and then you cut it very thin it's
like spanish-style ham they feed the
pigs just on acorns it's like the best
meat you can get in the world but
depending on the humidity and where you
are so you're using it throughout the
out the season it's not like
you get it on christmas and save it
you're actually like christmas day you
slice a little off then just leave it on
the counter like bread
well you you tone the shelf yeah it's on
a shelf i have like a specific spot for
it but it's open air there's a there's
there's a towel over the top of it yes
you're
that's airtight right yeah your upper
make that down
you're right to be a ghast right now but
wow i'm just trying to picture what it
actually is you're leaving it's old
[ __ ] pig you're leaving meat on on
the counter for six months and eating it
as you want right yeah and it already
comes in rotten you get it with a layer
of mold on the outside the fat in case
is it as you slice that fat off you
reveal delicious sweet tasty pink meat
and then as you get closer to the bone
there's something coming out from the
bone so like you hit that layer and
you're like it tastes kind of weird but
it is a you know
ham that's been out on the windowsill
for eight months
so yeah i eat that thing a lot and my
wife yells at me
what kind of towel i'm imagining a
broncos beach towel it's just a rally
towel
you got it this year boys
there's always a conversation right
around september there should be of my
wife being like you gotta throw it away
and i'm like no no there's still plenty
of meat on there and then i'm just
spitefully eating rotten ham
i'll show you yeah does it smell in the
house oh no no that's a yes no i mean
there's there's been rumors of it
smelling i can't tell because i'm so
annoyed i didn't kill bigfoot yeah yeah
exactly you guys eat and sash watch it
yeah it's the slaughterhouse reek but
it's good that's that's the flavor you
do have though
the idea behind that
is pretty classy that's what i'm saying
yeah like you're a foodie yeah and also
refined in certain ways like what i mean
like he can quote poetry but then he put
on a [ __ ] buffalo or a broncos jersey
thank you which is like here's my face
i had the seneca casino on my mind
akash you'll get yours
i'll be back to seek my vengeance he was
singing the dealer was singing
about the seneca one he was singing
which i thought was weird was
unprofessional he was singing
a casino what i mean
all sort of professionals and i do not
recommend the oysters
uh but like yeah he comes in with
chilled white wine but also
eats old meat for months yeah it's it's
like it's very crazy yeah well yeah i
feel like if uh if you're gonna have
like gross kind of almost pretentious
affectations
you still gotta be slime sure you know
so i try and keep that slimy layer on me
i'm pretty much like the pig leg i'm
just i'm just like i'm great meat but
i'm encased in a layer of poisonous fat
that's it you are the pygmy yeah i'm the
pig yeah
put a shelf up over here to keep sam
town there all year
[Laughter]
uh do you have a strong stomach a strong
constitution like do you get food
poisoning a lot or probably a license
plate in that thing yeah i was munching
hubcaps before i got here
i could be honestly i've had like food
poisoning the past like three days dude
i am dehydrated i don't think my eyes
are going to come out of my head we know
where sam's keeping his silver you know
what i mean
hey doc i know how much is in there too
yeah i don't get any ideas too swift i
counted that [ __ ]
two swiss passports and a clock
like jason you have a go bag i do
i do i am the go back
[Laughter]
i'm so sweaty
i look so gross on camera look great it
looks great i'll tell you it's like
summer school in here it's good time fun
yikes um
what is the grossest
gross is a strange word but
what is the most i think it's going to
be correct for whatever yeah what's the
grossest thing you've ever eaten
probably like uh the the rotted shark
meat that's uh indigenous to like
scandinavia oh my god andrew zimmerman
wouldn't even [ __ ] with that [ __ ] well
yeah but he's a guy
hollywood [ __ ] yeah what a baby
somebody went there it might have been
bourdain i think it was zimmer i
remember i love him yeah that he oh you
could smell it through the tv
[Laughter]
well i know he's a fan of the pod so
andy yeah
that's wild yeah that's rotten was it
good no it was terrible it tasted like
hairspray anything of it of like i can
see why this is cherished as a uh no
yeah no i know exactly what you're
talking about yeah like if that was the
uh the crown jewel in my culinary
history i would have died off really
yeah it's gross but i was in copenhagen
with my wife we were at a very nice
restaurant and it was served as part of
the you know the seven course thing and
i was like well i'm gonna try it yeah i
didn't finish it and that's very rare
i usually finish whatever's put in front
of me did she try it oh no no no no she
was pissed they brought it out sure
because it stunk up the table jesus
frog-like snails you'll do all that oh
love snails frog legs aren't my favorite
they're gross they're just gross yeah
it's not good they're never cooked
correctly they're always wet on the
inside
well snails is just a way to it's like a
conduit for butter and garlic sure i i
enjoy that long enough it's just like a
mushroom yeah yeah no yeah it just
doesn't really get me going everyone had
one though which is cool
i'm very big in the same thing in the
sense of like i'll try pretty much every
especially if we're at like a nice
restaurant yeah and it's good i'm like
well i know this chef knows what the
[ __ ] he's doing all right give me the
barbecue sauce and the mustard
i'm like this is going to be the best
version or like one of the best versions
of this i'll [ __ ] try it and he wants
you to enjoy it he wouldn't serve you
something as a dare he wants you to
actually try this thing because he
thinks he's done it correctly i'm
surprised you didn't do the marrow when
we went out to dinner are you yeah i've
i've had it as the with the asabuko
[Music]
place i worked at in philly had started
to [ __ ] with it but it was just the
little
the little john like the little nugget
it wasn't the [ __ ] like the [ __ ]
liver king long one yeah it was great
it's decadent yeah yeah it's just
natural butter yeah it's pure
cholesterol it's so good yeah yeah all
right yeah i don't know i mean yeah did
you used to do smear it on toast or did
you just eat it
they would they would give you a little
cocktail spoon with it with the dish and
the asabuko and you just you just kind
of ate it this was this was this is
going back probably 15 16 years before
it was like as trendy as it is now i
think cucumbers were hot back then
cucumber martini remember cucumbers
everywhere no
potatoes were in there yeah
it was a big year for pepper
sweet potatoes sweet potato fries are
everywhere
sweet potato fries had a run they did i
never got it again just give me a
regular fries did you eat anything weird
in australia you have any kangaroo or
allergy kangaroo tongue down there
well i did but the kangaroo meets pretty
good as [ __ ] up as it is it's okay
it's just tough to get over the fact
that you're eating just a giant rodent
you know are they rodents they're
they're like effectively related to the
rodent family is what ben told me they
are they're yeah they're adorable dicks
though right aren't they dicks uh they
can rip your face off yeah they'll steal
your credit yeah steal your silver bunch
of hackers uh-huh yeah they're like
angelina jolie
um no so i ate it and it was it was not
that good okay but the seafood down
there was great the coffee is amazing
really in australia australia australian
coffee i've never had any better really
how do you do your coffee iced all the
time no no that was just because i was
dripping like a ham in a window
like a ham on a shelf any humidity here
cause they come from zero humidity by
the way when i was in denver and salt
lake city
i for the first
five hours i was like this is nothing
and by the time we got on stage at the
denver comedy works which is a [ __ ]
phenomenal comedy club over there the
staff loved you guys unbelievable you
were supposed to come to that show and
then you flew out to australia oh my god
look it's all [ __ ] tying together i
texted him like because you're like hey
man i think it was your birthday was
that night and you're like oh cool i'm
gonna be in town come to the show you're
gonna be on the show yeah we're gonna
have you on the show and then
i'm like i haven't heard from [ __ ]
sam yeah and it was like we were like
flying in that day so i texted you i'm
like hey man are you still coming
tonight you're like i'm in australia i'm
like oh okay yeah tim sent me a just a
plane ticket randomly yeah he's like
you're coming why wouldn't you come why
wouldn't you come coming's good yeah
he's cool like that he's the greatest
he's really i'm i'm so grateful for his
channel mister tim [ __ ] yeah the man
yeah don't eat don't eat any tongue i
mean i love tongue but don't eat any
rodent tongue that's my
but what i'm saying is at denver and
salt lake city we were proper [ __ ] up
like i was dodging i thought i was
having a heart attack yeah yeah yeah it
was i got off stage and as i was passing
him he was about to go on i was like
if you feel it all the stages because
you're like
in combat when you're performing it's
like you're focused on your breath to
hit your punch lines and make sure you
can get everything out and it was like i
was like i was speaking another language
yeah like running out of breath so when
you come here it's the humidity it's the
humidity here but yeah also i grew up at
like 7 200 feet yeah so i yesterday i
walked eight miles and i was fine yeah
what you would be almost super human
yeah because i guess we produce more
white blood cells if you grow up if you
like that's why people train it out
yeah that's pretty good yeah so if if
aliens are out there i come at me all
right no but i'm saying i'll walk
if
it's difficult for us to go to [ __ ]
salt lake to here with the humidity in
different parts of the country it'd be
brutal with different [ __ ]
atmospheres and gravity and stuff like
that so you think they definitely got
spacesuits on right they're not just
walking around yeah they figured out how
to get to a different galaxy i think
they'll figure out how to respirate when
they arrive
i know she said breathe
that's what i love i love it no because
you'll need it you'll need equipment
you'll need a respirator that's very
true i didn't think about that i was
thinking about it in the shower or uh
yesterday the way you talk sam is if i
was to use a word
you picked the third word on the list
from a thesaurus that i would use well i
think that you probably wouldn't know of
course yeah they would have a message
i understand four words this guy said
this whole thing he's an intelligent
he's a [ __ ] author what do you mean
a little bit of silver hear me jingle
jangle
you hear me coming down his money
doesn't fold baby no assault
i have a question for you guys please
is it garbage
to
[Music]
watch your dog be euthanized over
facetime i just did this the other
yesterday
um it's a friend of yours it sounds like
it sounds like a personal this was me on
wednesday night yeah i'm so sorry thank
you sorry to hear so sorry yeah thank
you how long did you have him 14 years
wow yeah he had a good run i asked him
was like there's something you know like
what was he saying or he hurt or
something he goes now we were just over
it yeah yeah
we wanted to travel yeah we can't fly
with these he kept ordering movies on
pay-per-view right yeah
i [ __ ] told him one more time this is
a bad roommate
yeah my wife called me when i got off
the plane she's like you got to come
back home i was like what and she's like
yeah the the vet's coming over right now
his gums are purple
i was like trying to hang out with toby
and the boys you know having fun at the
giggle show and meanwhile i'm just down
the street pounding narragansetts
watching my dog take his last breaths
they came to the house to do it yeah so
she called and said hey the dogs the
dog's not feeling while the vet's coming
did she know it was really really bad or
like yeah so she he was coming
to euthanize him not like let me give
him check him out see what we can do for
him yeah my wife she's a human doctor so
she she could tell the gums were
discolored
yeah
sorry to hear that man sorry thanks
i don't think it's no that's not true i
mean if you were on like the subway or
something like other people made other
people part of it if you're in a mascot
helmet
what the [ __ ] yeah
damn but i do think that
i don't know that's classy not classy
but it's not trashy okay i think it
afforded you
that's like the one thing with
technology is like it's sad i can tell
you that yeah but it affords you the to
be able to be there that last moment
yeah kind of you know what i mean i also
i took a bunch of snap shots of the
facetime
of her like my wife like
saying goodbye so now i just have like
gordy's death in still frame so i'm
going to flip through when you got a
couple yeah yeah
we know when you're drinking
and you it's like you're sad and you're
like i want to get real sad right cut me
baby oh yeah you start looking through
old pics throwing a little jim crochet
[ __ ] really let them pour out you
know it's going to be bad though at some
point your phone is just going to put
those all into like an album oh my god
it'll be like your fairy friend and just
like the worst moment of your life for
the harry styles song behind it
[Laughter]
jesus happy happy birthday happy happy
birthday yeah it's gonna be me walking
gordy through the park yeah me feeding
him his favorite food and then just a
syringe cold dead eyes
yeah just two marbles trapped in his
head yeah dad gave him they gave me a
needle oh yeah okay yeah
no no they put him in a pillowcase and
had a ball pete hammer
they gave him a handgun
do it yourself don't be a [ __ ] at the
end of the casino him and his brother
went
did you did and did they take him away
or did you bury him no my they were like
what do you want us to do and my wife
was like well it's not him anymore so
she just put him in a trash bag and gave
it to the vet to take out i don't know
where he is now
hell probably
knowing his views
yeah his lifestyle
dog's going to hell yeah that's pretty
funny
write up the treatment
dogs in hell
very sorry about that thanks man now is
that was that the only dog you had yeah
are you gonna get i know of
are you gonna get another will you guys
get a puppy no dude really yeah cause we
wanna like she's gonna be a travel
doctor next year what does that mean
she's gonna go around to different uh
places and be a doctor wait i mean there
was only two words travel doctor piece
it together use context clues i didn't
know if that meant she meant like home
home calls or whatever they're called no
no so she'll like take a contract in new
york take a contract in chicago is she
licensed everywhere yeah yeah doctors
can practice anywhere really in the
states in canada and i think most
english speakers not electronics not
like real estate yeah
they're not doing auto inspections
now she's gonna talk to the union about
that or what's the deal well that's
pretty cool are you guys gonna
coordinate this what's what's the plan
that's that's classy that's oh it'll be
exciting yeah and eventually like long
term probably moved to spain we're both
learning spanish i also graduated from
college the last time since i've been
here yeah that's guys
yeah
thanks my hands are so wet
it's like they've been in a pumpkin for
an hour
it's a protective mold around what's
happening have you done that before and
how do you know what that feels like oh
dude i love scooping guts
university metro state university of
denver nice go road runners there you go
that's a squad this year huh oh dude
they're very good at women's volleyball
really yeah they don't have a football
sounds like a cell phone provider
[Laughter]
you guys want to sign up by any chance
you you guys want to graduate ten year
contract jesus christ don't text me i
only have 10 left this month
yeah
would you like to go i wonder he was a
basque country kind of guy uh no
probably barcelona love barcelona my
girl is literally on her way there right
now oh dude hopefully she comes back
hopefully just her comes back
yeah
yeah so i don't know that's i just like
their life is the world's so big
i want to get out well aware and it's
tough because like i love stand-up but
i've done stand-up since i was like 18.
i've been on the road since i was 18.
would you go on the road from there
would you just
would you just make that your home base
and like travel from there i think so
man huh yeah i think i'm gonna go over
to the uk with stan hope in september
okay i'm just trying to like set myself
up to do stand-up uh in as many places
globally because i've done every state
besides delaware
if you guys have any delaware listeners
you want to bring me in there so i can
get number [ __ ] we've got a bunch of
them oh yeah so that's the only state is
delaware yeah
damn i'm not like you know right out of
my way
yeah it's like the mayor uh-huh
he's like a cartoon wow ian he's so
funny cousin ian we love him yeah wait
you you did stand up in alaska yeah
how was that where do you think the
silver's buried yeah
he just slices your throat and walks out
of the room
that's what's so crazy is i can picture
you little db cooper
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] yes
[Applause]
suitcase in a fake mustache
now look straight ahead on the plane as
i jump out of the back of this megabus
ladies and gentlemen mr sand palin
buddy we [ __ ] love you we love having
you here man love you guys so happy for
y'all great time you got anything you
want the folks out there to know what do
you got what you got coming up you were
talking about a novella oh yeah i got a
novella on audible it's only available
on audible but it's free it's called
attaboy uh and then my podcast chubby
behemoth listen to that we're pretty
much
western expansion of the philadelphia
podcast empire i love that yeah because
of all my appearances on y'all's pods
and stuff like we get a lot of so yeah
if you like this kind of stuff chubby
behemoth love fantastic i love you buddy
thank you so much i got a towel off
uh guys we got we just announced more
dates we're all over the [ __ ] we got
philly boston providence [ __ ]
nashville kansas everywhere uh link is
in the description check it the [ __ ] out
number one is run back new jersey august
11th do yourselves a flight that's about
to be sold out get those [ __ ] tickets
this is about to sell out yeah we love
you we'll see you next week